I just read and read and read I probably
read five to six hours a day if you want
to change where you are then you need to
change who you are
I consider reading to be like part of my
job rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's up believe nation its Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so grab a cup of coffee and sip on
today's message read read read over to
you Warren Buffett I just read and read
and read I probably read five to six
hours a day I don't read as fast now as
when I was younger but I read five daily
newspapers I read a fair number of
magazines I read 10 Kay's I read annual
reports and I read a lot of other things
to the side-eye
I've always enjoyed reading I love
reading biographies for example if you
want to change where you are then you
need to change who you are you are a
direct result of the environment that
you're in of the people that you hang
out with of the habits that you do
regularly and of the media and
information that you consume on a
regular basis you are where you are in
life because of your parents because of
your friends because of the books you
are reading or not reading because of
the Netflix shows or YouTube channels
that you are watching or not watching
and if you want to change where you are
in life you need to grow as a human
being you need to change who you are one
of the great great great advantages of
reading is that you get to take lessons
and it may have taken somebody else
decades to learn and they've consumed it
and they've written it into a book
decades sometimes of research and
knowledge that you can consume in a
couple of hours and immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
it's a cheat it's a hack and for a lot
of you you may not have a great circle
of friends you may not have the ability
to go out and network with people you
may live in a tiny town you may have
family that doesn't support you and so a
lot of you will then say well that's my
lot in life and I'm screwed and I can
never change that
no you
change it by reading write by reading
you are hanging out with people who've
done a lot more than you and the more
that you are hanging around those people
even if they're not in front of you it'd
be amazing to have Tony Robbins sit with
you every single day and help guide you
through life
but because you can't have that you can
have his books you can learn from him
you can apply all of his lessons into
your life on a daily basis and start
seeing growth and that applies to any of
the authors that you might look up to I
take this even a step further in that as
my video consumption has come up I've
read less and less and less I still read
I'm not happy with how much I'm reading
I probably read a couple of nights a
week I try to make it a daily practice
so it's one of the things up I'm working
on but I consume a ton of YouTube
content I much prefer watching videos
than reading a book that's where my
mindset is that it's why I make videos
for you guys it's why I do the top ten
series in the mentor me series
especially because I selfishly mean I
want to hang on people who've done so
much more than me and the more that I'm
hanging around those people the more
their mind sets their way of thinking
their attitudes their belief seeps into
me to allow me to go off and do bigger
things
Elon Musk and Tony Robbins and Mel
Robbins and et and all the people Warren
Buffett that I profile I feel like are
my friends like these are my
acquaintances these are guys and ladies
that are in my ear constantly pushing me
to do more to strive for greater things
because the people in my life don't the
people in my life are great and I'm so
fortunate to have people who are
actually supportive of everything that
I'm doing but nobody's telling me Evan
you saw you could be doing more like
what you've done is great but I know you
could be doing a lot more and the amount
of growth that I have seen in the past
couple years I attribute exactly to the
video content that I have consumed and
made for you guys and I guarantee you
whether it's watching YouTube videos
like mine whether it's reading a book a
day you know whether it's consuming just
content that inspires you on a regular
basis if you were doing that if you made
it a daily habit a daily practice to
consume content whether that's from a
book or video or friends or conferences
or meetups whatever the thing is that
gets you feeling like you
could do more you could be greater you
could accomplish bigger things right if
you did that on a daily basis whatever
the thing that made you feel bold on a
daily basis I guarantee you that your
life will be unrecognizable
from where you are in one year from
today your change will be insane and so
there's that famous quote that says you
are the direct result of the five people
that you spend the most time with right
and that's very true if you look at the
five people who you spend the most time
with they're probably around the same
spot that you are
and so the hack that sheet the shortcut
to get to a better place
is through aspirational mentors it's
through books it's through videos and so
I would encourage you strongly to really
do it audit of how you are spending your
time what kind of content information
you are consuming on a regular basis and
is that contributing to you on tapping
the inner potential that you have to go
off and do amazing things and if not
then let's change it now I've got some
very special bonus clips for you but
before that commitment of the day you
just watch this video hopefully it
resonated with you don't watch another
video and not take action I want you to
commit in the comments below what is one
thing that you are going to change in
your schedule in your habits in your
life in your business as a result of
watching that video commit publicly
leave it down the comments below I want
to see what you are up to thank you so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clips
you
I want you to read one self-help book
it's not a lot just one per month that's
not a lot you can handle that most
self-help books are pretty short so all
you need to do is just have a list and
in fact I have a list of some of my
favorite most powerful self-help books
on my website you can go check that out
actualize that org but this is this is a
huge habit here's why because self-help
books have basically distilled all the
principles of success and happiness that
human beings have discovered in the last
2,000 years and especially the last
hundred years there's been so much
research done on how to be successful in
business how to be successful in
relationships how to be successful with
your happiness levels how to meditate
properly the scientific benefits of
meditation and so on and so forth and
self-help books are not just abstract
you know very pedantic type of books
that you might read in college these are
very practical these are written to get
you results these self-help books have
exercises in them they have techniques
read those start practicing those if you
just read one book per month for the
next let's say eight years that would be
close to a hundred books that would give
you the entire theoretical foundation
that you need to master life the
exercise is very important the creative
process I try to either run a run or
swim almost run swim where I do CrossFit
every day and that's like that's very
important i I tend to have like creative
breakthroughs when I've stopped working
on something and I've went to do
something else which is cool you're
showing me the gym earlier I think
that's probably why that's there it's
like you can work and work and work on a
problem then you stop and then when
you're thinking about something else
that sort of magically comes together in
your mind's books obviously are very
important I read a lot I try to read
like two or three books a week and I for
me what I'm a I realized very early on
and it's a little bit clearer for me
because I work in book publishing and
I'm a writer but like I consider reading
to be like part of my job so
like that was actually somewhat weird
when I was working full time at American
Apparel it's like I would want to sit
there and like read a book but you know
I can't do that at an office you know
but so now I work from home so I can
sort of do
I can arrange my day in a way that like
appearances matter a little bit less but
I think you know reading but what I what
I say is like okay look chances are
whatever problem you're going through
right now someone else went through
before you and they probably wrote it
down and so like books are the way that
we we access that knowledge and if
you're not availing yourself to it
you're gonna learn a lot of things the
hard way when you don't necessarily need
to so I consider like leading to be like
part of my job and part of what's
accelerated what I've been able to
accomplish and I did so it's like when
people are like oh how do you have time
how do you have so much time to read
it's like well how do you have time to
sleep and how do you have time to eat
and go to work like that's just what you
do it's not like this extra luxury that
I squeezed in when I'm on vacation that
was gonna be one of my questions how do
you have that yeah under read so there's
no secret and like I don't read fast
like I think a lot of people think that
people who read a lot must be like speed
readers and so they focus on that it's
like no people who read a lot just spend
a lot of time reading because it's
important to them and that's sort of the
distinction that I mean if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you Apple that would
be collect a little beacon hey believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details